Hi everybody, Ashley here, and our topic today is Caster Oil.
The Caster Oil actually comes from the Caster Bean.
It has been around for thousands of years for health purposes, and it is really known
for its topical pain reliever properties.
Nowadays it is also included in our beauty industry as well.
This applies you need as going to be a container in which you put your Caster Oil in.
You will also use a piece of cloth that has no dyes in it that will soak the Caster Oil itself
and then you apply that to your skin.
When choosing a Caster Oil, it is preferred that you get a cold pressed, hexane-free and
preferably organic Caster Oil.
What Caster Oil can help with is going to be increasing circulation, promote elimination,
healing of tissues and organs under the skin.
It can stimulate the liver, relieve pain, increase lymphatic circulation, reduce inflammation
and improve digestion.
It can also help with things like sprains, insomnia, dry skin and even scars.
More benefits include the beauty industry piece of it, which is going to be stimulating
hair growth, apply to your skin for some skin benefits as, like, puffiness wringling
those types of things and also for swollen lymph nodes as well.
For more information on Caster Oil and also to purchase any Caster Oil supplies, visit
ConnorsClinic.com in our web store.
Thank you.